here's a big-time movie star on the big
friend his latest film is called first
performed it's terrific opens May 18th
ethan hawke a gentleman i finally got
you here took a long time but such a big
fan of yours I would say I would see you
even in a bad movie but you don't ever
do a bad movie
yeah I've done some like what's a bad
one you've done well why would I bring
it up I like the way you think I was
almost on the show for the movie good
kill I loved that much yeah it was it's
a strange movie because it doesn't have
any friends
that movie because it's it's about the
drone program and I play a pilot and you
know doing all these drone strikes and
the effect that it has pilots and the
left hated that movie because it was
anti Obama and the right hated the movie
because it perceived as anti military
and so nobody cared about it but it's a
very smart movement it's a very well
that's the bigger problem is that smart
movies of any kind don't have fans
movies to me there's only like two kinds
of movies two blockbuster robots and
monsters and then movies like this that
I see in a hotel room and you have to
seek those movies out you know you
really do and that's one of the things
that is I've noticed more and more is
that we're all actually only as good as
our time period we're only really as
good as our community and our
surrounding when I think about the
movies that I grow up what watching take
one for the Cuckoo's Nest something like
a movie that movies a great film but it
was made by a studio studio put it out
in the malls everybody went to see it it
got awards but now that's an art film or
I don't even know if they would make
that wouldn't they wouldn't because it's
got a sad ending but it's it's a strange
thing the more they feed people popcorn
the more people just want pop well it's
I guess it's either the robot movies or
the ones that win the awards that people
don't see I mean I finally caught up to
a fish called
water no fish called one that's a long
time finally caught up with a fish
called lawanda
shape of water shape of water yeah yeah
yeah yeah
the shaker boy and I said on the show
when I hadn't I said I think I'm gonna
hate it I didn't hate it
mm-hm I thought it was kind of you like
the fish better than you thought you
would well I mean it's its first words
it's an old story about a you know a
woman who falls for a you know King Kong
Beauty and the Beast
yeah cause if moto men are so bad women
black what was that swamp movie creature
from them yeah black right yeah yeah and
it's always the same thing that men are
so bad that women will actually go out
with a monster or an animal or Quasimodo
and form pretty nice to me and I will go
out with you I will [ __ ] a fish before I
okay so but let's let's plug the movie
up coming out right say it's called
first or fourth
yes it's terrific I saw it you did loved
it yes because again it's it's a movie
you know I love movies where the
character where you see why somebody
changes and it's realistic because that
doesn't happen a lot even in life so in
this movie you played this pastor right
I'm not gonna give too much of it away
but you give counseling to a guy who is
almost on the verge of being what I
would call an eco-terrorist
I mean he is there he is on the verge of
right he's in a serious very serious in
the impact that the planets on fire
right he doesn't want to bring a child
into this world how do I explain to my
daughter that right I brought you into a
world that's on fire and nobody cares
and and your character a pastor and you
know religion very often is not on the
forefront of fighting for the
environment becomes an environmentalist
of sorts I mean the movies about more
than that but I thought that part I
thought was just terrific well it's
written by Paul Schrader who write taxi
driver is along with many other great
great films and he's he's
what I love about is every now and then
a writer a really fine writer can give
voice to something that we're all
thinking about it's like an unanswerable
question is something you know when you
you have these thoughts in your head and
you're upset and you're watching the TV
and you hear people arguing and you want
to believe in God and you have faith and
you're watching you the world and you
can't make sense out of it and art great
song a great piece of music a great
movie can ask the question that will
vibrate within you it doesn't give you
an answer it just gives you access to
your own voice and I think Paul did that
with taxi-driver and he's done that was
many films and this felt like an honor
being a part of this movie because he's
he's speaking to right now where is our
we call ourselves a Christian country
you hear that spoken about a lot and
what are we asking of ourselves in
regards to leadership and stewardship of
God's earth right now why did God bust
his ass to make this beautiful planet
for six days we now have us rat-fuck it
really is the question he's asked it's a
question and it's a question how that
intersects with depression right how
that intersects with love and hope where
do we carry hope where do we carry
despair what what's worth fighting for
and one of the things that's super
interesting about the movie is my my
priest he's he's working at an old
parish that used to be a part of the
Underground Railroad right yeah and he
gives these little tours about the
Underground Railroad and we all come to
view social activism or is even gsella
tree of what those you know the
abolitionists were risking their lives
and people thought they were crazy the
same way they might think an
eco-terrorist is crazy now and it's an
interesting
Schrader's puts my character in a really
interesting position because all day I'm
talking about these abolitionists and
how much with the benefit of time we
respect them well what do we you know we
were easy to write off these diehard
environmentalists people that are
willing to hang themselves from trees or
stand in the front of a
you know this kids is standing rock that
don't have good water you'll be all
watching this happen and what are we
willing to do about it
you know what and we're so grateful to
those abolitionists now well what are we
doing now it's a good question
it's a great question